نحن في رحلة استكشافية عبر
غابات باتاغونيا البرية
[الموسيقى]
من غاباتها المطيرة الشمالية
إلى طرف أمريكا الجنوبية حيث يتعين على
الأشجار أن تتخلص من
فصول الشتاء شديدة البرودة
[موسيقى]
غابات مليئة بمجموعة من المخلوقات المعجزة التي
لا يوجد الكثير منها في أي مكان آخر  على الأرض
[الموسيقى]
اليوم ، على الرغم من أن
هذه الغابات القديمة محاصرة
أحيانًا من تهديدات مفاجئة ،
فهذه
هي
أكثر الأشجار شهرة في
[موسيقى] araucarias patagonia
نظرًا لتفرعها المعقد ،
تُعرف أيضًا
بألغاز القرود
[الموسيقى] التي
لا توجد إلا في جنوب أمريكا الجنوبية
كانت ذات مرة أكثر شيوعًا
[موسيقى]
كانت معلقة في بضع مناطق نائية
متناثرة على طول منحدرات
براكين باتاغونيا في كل من تشيلي والأرجنتين التي
تصل إلى 160 قدمًا ،
هؤلاء العمالقة هم من الناجين من
العصر الجوراسي منذ
أكثر من 145 مليون سنة
[  الموسيقى]
تطورت الأوراق الشوكية المتميزة كوسيلة
دفاع ضد
الديناصورات الجائعة طويلة العنق
ولكن زوار اليوم أقل
تدميراً
[الموسيقى]
مع  آه ، لقد
قاموا بتربية ببغاء أسترالي مضرب ،
وهو نوع من أنواع الببغاوات الواقعة في أقصى الجنوب على
الأرض
[موسيقى] ،
وهو
إسفنجة مضطربة تتنقل من شجرة إلى أخرى في أسراب
تصل إلى 15 طائرًا
عندما يجدون مكانًا جيدًا
للتغذية يمكن أن يتضخم إلى أكثر من مائة
[موسيقى  ]
طريقتهم المفضلة للتسمين للشتاء
التهام حبات الصنوبر القرد
[الموسيقى]
في المقابل تنشر الطيور البذور على
نطاق واسع
[موسيقى]
ولكن الببغاوات ليست الوحيدة
هنا لحصاد
[موسيقى
] المابوتشي
السكان الأصليون الذين عاشوا هنا
منذ ما يقرب من 3000 عام
يعتمدون على هذه البذور في الطعام
ويطحنونها في الدقيق لصنع الخبز